khabib 26 victories no defeats 26 oh no
never lost a round in the UFC what do
you think the crack is in his defense do
you see his weakness I believe he has
many weaknesses in his game he
specialized from the Tagus town region
they specialize in wrestling the kid
wrestled bears when he was a baby it's
part of their culture so I am I'm under
no illusion that he's a skilled wrestler
of course fighting in in the whole
picture there's many more and facets to
fighting a lot more than just one single
discipline thankfully now I am not
locked into a specific rule set similar
to my last match I am free to fight as I
please so that's what I will do i have
many many weapons to dismantle all
styles of opponent and this is just
another style of opponent I believe he's
slow he's flat-footed his striking is
very average and I look to expose that
on Saturday night I'm curious you said
that and this is true some people
thought you were making a joke khabib
father did have him fight a bear when he
was a child I would never want to fight
anybody who fought a bear
as a child he may have he may have
wrestled daghestani bears but he has
never wrestled an Irish gorilla Conan
and that's what
[Applause]
you